i don't talk about d d enough on here
okay i need to talk about something that
is going on in the dnd campaign that i'm
part of it's called quill and sword you
can find the back episodes on youtube
and it streams on twitch so stephen
partridge who is the dm and also a
friend of mine i knew him before we even
started this thing he decided not too
far into the campaign to introduce a
chosen one narrative for my character
now he knows me well enough to know i
hate chosen one stories but i did agree
to let him do this because i basically
decided to use my character as a vent
for my own frustrations with the entire
trope so that was the first thing that
happened and then
in the most recent session after i had
accepted that through all the
shenanigans i've gone through my
character was going to die he had the
character saved literally by the power
of friendship so he introduced a trope
by despise and then rounded out the ark
with a trope i'm highly skeptical of and
you know what it has resulted in the
most rewarding d d session i've ever
been a part of damn you steven that was
so good